are you limited in any way is there a
next step for you to get to as far as
what you can do physically or restricted
in any way shape or form at this time no
i wouldn't say i'm necessarily limited i
think we're just being cautious and uh
being smart in the fact of
i'm not doing things when there's a pass
rush or guys you know potentially
falling at the legs or so or something
of that nature but
um as far as saying i can't do drills or
i can't do something uh i'm pretty much
full go
good news for the cowboys dak prescott
recovering from the ankle injury he told
espn over the weekend that he could play
in the game right now if he had to the
good news for him and the cowboys is he
doesn't have to for a few more months
they'll continue to keep him protected
quarterbacks are anyway they got the red
jersey don't go close to him don't go
near him and definitely don't touch them
during practice it'll be that first
preseason game yeah that he happens to
be on the field and who knows how the
reps are going to be divided among
starters and backups when you only have
three preseason games because you still
have to evaluate your full roster and
you got to decide who you're going to
keep and not keep on the back end so
it's not like you need to see what dak
can do and they may be inclined to give
him limited work it may not be until
week one thursday night opener at tampa
bay that dak prescott really is facing
that live fire in the backfield as he
tests out the ankle on a repeated basis
yeah i mean you see him moving there i
mean he's not moving 100 there so yeah
he might you know he might be able to
play a game but he's not going to be
totally full 100 percent what we expect
out of that you're not going to sprint
you're not going to sprint around in
those drills no you're right even if
you're completely healthy no i get it
but i could i could still tell there's
favoring it just watching it there to
know that that's not the look or the
move of a guy that's a hundred percent
got the same pop in his leg not that i'm
concerned about it i'm just saying thank
you just an opportunity i saw no hitch
in the giddy up as they say
he looked fine to me well you well i
mean we can play it back if you want to
watch it again look back but either way
listen do it live i feel good about
where he's at i do i mean they have to
feel good yeah that's really good watch
when he drops back here in a second
after getting doing the high knee okay
all right let's see what you got
professional
after this here we go right here look
that's not he didn't explode out and you
could tell there was a little bit of a
it's a
it's a drill
in otas he's not going to explode out of
that that's my point it doesn't matter
about the explosion
there's a favoring of the leg i don't
know what we're arguing about either way
yeah i i i expect them out there week
one and you're right i mean they're
gonna be careful with them i don't know
what we're arguing about is a different
way of saying i yield no i don't know
what you're arguing about because i'm
wrong i'm passing it on because i'm
going i no i've given i give up okay i
don't know i watch men's bodies and do
these things all the time and i saw an
issue there that's why i'm just moving
on i'm not going to argue about it right
anymore but but they got to be careful
about those live reps to your point what
you're talking about i can speak to that
like wholeheartedly because even when
you're in those you know red jerseys and
everything like that
got you get that like third guy at the
defensive end right mike who's johnny
tryhard he's trying to make it you know
sometimes they lose control of their
body they're trying so hard to go around
the edge and do things like that they
fall down they slip they do things like
that and they fall on the quarterback's
leg it actually happened to me when i
lost my spleen i remember one of the
first live things i was in an ota
somebody hit me from the back side like
a johnny tryhard trying to make the team
and a big f fight broke out you know of
course because i'm covering recovering
from the spleen but it does happen from
time to time is my point
where were you favoring your spleen
identity yeah yeah i was i was falling
apart like i literally was getting worse
by the day
and every day going like expecting to
get better as i go out there and throw
but every day like things were shutting
off more and more and i couldn't figure
it out and then one day i give a handoff
to cadillac williams and i stick my hand
out there and he kind of like
grabbed at it real hard and took it and
my damn bicep tendon tore off my arm i
mean it just it was an avalanche of
issues right there
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports